welcome
my name is michael mann and i'm a
thoracic surgeon at the university of
california here in san francisco i'm
also director of our cardiothoracic
translational research laboratory
and i have the privilege of talking to
you today about our work
in developing a better approach for
molecular prognosis that can be
implemented today in the management of
our early stage non-small cell lung
cancer patients and in particular those
with a non-squamous histology
i'd like to just mention at the outset
that i am a consultant for life
technologies corporation
and they are the entity that has taken
over the molecular assay uh that we're
going to talk about most of uh today's
discussion
that assay is now available uh
commercially for any patient really
around the world
it's known as the provenio
lung rs test
and as you'll see through the course of
today's lecture uh i'm hoping to
convince you
that it may be a very important uh and
meaningful component in the better
management of patients with early stage
non-squamous non-small cell lung cancer
now
hopefully
many of you are familiar with
developments in the use of molecular
prognostics
for cancer
that have really evolved dramatically
over the past decade and our colleagues
in the field of breast cancer really
deserve
an enormous amount of credit
for pioneering that work and making the
use of molecular
prognosis
a very well established part of the
standard of care for early stage breast
cancer
so hopefully i don't need to convince
you of the relevance and the clinical
validity
of the use of molecular prognosis to
augment and to enhance
conventional prognostic indicators such
as those that feed into the standard tnm
staging system
but what i do hope to convince you of
is that a very well validated
tool is now available for non-squamous
non-small cell lung cancer patients
and not only is that tool available to
provide better prognostic information
but that that tool can be implemented
today
even given the remainder of the of the
base of literature and clinical
knowledge that we have to lead to more
informed management
of patients with non-squamous non-small
cell lung cancer in our clinics today
now
i've listed some objectives for this for
this next hour
we'll talk about the need initially for
better prognostic information in
managing these patients
as i mentioned we'll talk about the
immediate clinical utility of this
improved information and then
run through
the valid the development and the
validation of a multi-gene test that is
now available as i mentioned uh for
patients and their doctors around the
world
what is the problem that we're
addressing well
we just had a brand new staging system
introduced
only a few years ago to guide the
management of non-small cell lung cancer
it's a seventh edition of the ajcc tnm
staging system
and
it involves thousands of patients from
databases from around the world
one thing i'd like to point out
the number one hundred thousand cases is
often mentioned when people think about
this new staging system because that was
the total number of patient uh
cases available
for development of this new staging
system
but we only had available
roughly sixteen thousand patients for
uh derivation and validation of this new
staging system
because we only had complete data about
that number of patients
when it boils down to it only about two
thousand of those patients were stage
one patients uh used in the actual
validation of this new system and i'll
remind you about that number uh when we
talk a little bit later about the
validation of the molecular prognostic
that's uh now available and and in the
medical literature
but when we think about t m staging of
course
it is really nothing more than a
prognostic system also based on
retrospective data analysis
and unfortunately in non-small cell lung
cancer we don't really get a very crisp
and very well differentiated picture of
our earliest stage patients and that's
highlighted by the disappointing figure
that as many as 30 percent in stage 1a
and 45 percent roughly in stage 1b
are patients who are going to die within
five years of their
operation which was intended to be
curative
when you compare that to stage one data
from other very common uh solid tumors
such as breast cancer or even colon
cancer those numbers really compare uh
very starkly and in a very disappointing
way to the greater than 90 percent
survival
that we're able to achieve with those
other
cancers and so really
there is a bit of a failure
relying entirely on traditional clinical
pathologic information such as that in
the tnm system to truly discriminate
between patients who have been cured by
surgery who certainly should have a
greater than 90 5-year survival and
those patients who haven't been cured by
surgery
well what does it mean that they haven't
been cured by surgery as we'll go as
we'll emphasize uh in a little bit that
means that if they're gonna fail within
five years with distant disease there
must be undetected metastatic disease
even present at the time of their uh
initial operation
another thing to remember about the
staging system and trying to manage
patients uh in stages one and two who
are almost uh always candidates
for
potentially curative resection is that
the number of patients with early stage
lung cancer is going to continue to grow
as
movements towards screening and just the
more wider implementation of
imaging modalities becomes even more
firmly established so these patients are
going to become a bigger piece of the
pie and an increasingly important
challenge in terms of improving what is
now
not really acceptable survival for such
early stage disease
okay
backing up uh why do so many early stage
lung cancer patients end up dying within
five years of operation of course these
tend to be older patients the average
age of diagnosis and non-small cell lung
cancer is still
somewhere between 65 and 70
and the patients their patients who have
a high
uh degree of smoking histories and other
comorbidities
so certainly there are other things that
threaten the longevity of these patients
but
when you think about early stage
patients in stages one and stage two
who've undergone attempted curative
operation the vast vast majority and
maybe 90 percent of these patients
eventually succumb to recurrent disease
and that recurrent disease almost always
involves distant metastases so as we
said a few minutes ago
the stage 1 and stage 2 patients
although presumably to the best of our
ability to analyze traditional clinical
pathologic information
and traditional imaging modalities only
have
local or regional disease
if they recur distantly within five
years that means they must be harboring
undetected
metastatic disease perhaps micro
metastatic disease at the time of their
operation
well so what
let's say we were able to better
differentiate these early stage patients
and know with greater certainty which
subgroup among those patients is at the
highest risk for harboring
micrometastatic disease what can we do
with that information
well
there's a large percentage of our
patients that fall into that category if
we consider operative patients in stage
two
it's actually the majority of patients
who are likely this to succumb to a
distant recurrent disease uh within five
years of operation
but there is something that we can do
we know that the adjuvant treatment of
non-small cell lung cancer with
chemotherapy early after surgery
actually improves five-year survival it
improves long-term survival that
improvement in survival is not the same
improvement that we see with the
treatment of late stage disease even
with the same chemotherapy agents
because in late stage disease we're very
satisfied if we get a few months or
certainly if we get a year or two of
additional survival after the patient's
diagnosis
but when we treat these patients early
after surgery who have only undetectable
or micro metastatic disease we're hoping
to get long-term survival if not
absolute cure we're looking at least for
something closer to an increase in
five-year survival which means that
there's a qualitative difference
in treating early stage perhaps
micrometastatic
lung cancer even though it's spread
beyond the original tumor and even
beyond regional lymph nodes
there's a qualitative difference between
treating those patients with
systemic chemotherapy and treating
patients in late stage disease when they
have macroscopic burdens of metastasis
because we can achieve long-term
cure
and and perhaps just long-term control
of a disease that really
is not part of the picture when we're
dealing with
macroscopic late stage disease so there
really is quite a bit on the table here
there's a lot at stake and we may
actually be saving lives if we can
identify more of these early stage
patients
who are likely to harbor undetectable
micro metastatic disease and who could
potentially be candidates
for shall we say it a curative
intervention through systemic
chemotherapy
all right well how does this fit into
the actual management of our patients
after surgery
let's think about stages two and stage
one separately because right now there's
a slightly different approach to their
management
so through the existing literature
of which have been at least three very
large scale scale very well accepted uh
prospective studies that have documented
a benefit of adjuvant chemotherapy
for these resected non-small cell lung
cancer patients
stage two and stage three are the are
these
subpopulations of resected patients in
whom we've been able to very clearly
document a survival benefit with the
adjuvant intervention
however even though there are pretty
firm recommendations for these stage two
patients to receive adjuvant
chemotherapy we all know that compliance
with that recommendation is certainly
far from a hundred percent
now to be sure uh these elderly patients
do include a subpopulation who just may
not be candidates for uh
aggressive chemotherapeutic intervention
particularly the platinum doublets that
are really the mainstay of chemotherapy
for this disease but there are also
stage two patients who would be
acceptable candidates for chemotherapy
who forego that intervention now now
remember they're dealing with statistics
from studies that have not been able to
differentiate between the highest risk
and the lowest risk patients in stage
two because remember even in stage two
we're dealing with
maybe fifty percent maybe slightly
smaller percent of patients who've been
cured by surgery alone
so if we treat the entire population
with chemotherapy we're treating an
awful lot of patients and we're studying
the outcomes for an awful lot of
patients for whom that chemotherapy is
absolutely of no help patients who've
been cured through surgery alone
but we haven't been able in those
studies
to really carefully differentiate
and identify the patients who are at
high risk
for recurrence which means they're at
high risk for harboring undetected
metastatic disease well if we were able
to ferret out the patients who couldn't
possibly benefit from systemic
intervention
and then look again at the survival
benefit that must be concentrated in the
patients who are at high risk for
disease the relatively small survival
benefit and we all remember the numbers
from the yalt study the anita study
and
the jbr 10 study in which the survival
benefit was an absolute somewhere
between 5 to 10 to 15 percent
that absolute survival benefit is going
to be even greater if we're able to
focus only on the patients who are truly
likely to harbor metastatic disease
we also know just from analysis of the
data from those studies that we have not
surprisingly tended to see the largest
degree of benefit in patients who are in
the highest risk
how do we know they were at the highest
risk when we compare stage 3 patients to
stage 2 patients we tend to see a larger
degree of benefit from chemotherapy
same is true when we compare stage two
to stage one
and so
realizing that we don't have any
biological basis to believe that the
micro metastatic or undetected
metastatic disease in stages two or even
stage one non-small cell lung cancer is
biologically inherently different from
the undetected disease in stage three or
for example stage two b
it stands to reason that if we can
identify the patients who are at high
risk
in stage one and certainly in stage two
that those patients are likely to derive
even more benefit than the current
literature would suggest from adjuvant
intervention now we're talking about a
much higher degree of motivation for
those high risk patients to engage with
their oncologists and their doctors
to pursue a means of improving what
could otherwise be fairly dismal uh
prospects for long-term survival
now that's stage two what about stage
one
well again we're all familiar with the
results of those adjuvant trials in
which it's really been
difficult if not impossible to nail down
a documentable survival benefit for
stage one patients from adjuvant
chemotherapeutic intervention
but even though we don't have hard
level one data behind us
the nccn has actually come out for the
past several iterations
for a number of years now with a fairly
firm recommendation that clinicians need
to recognize the very high incidence of
undetected metastatic disease among
stage 1 patients and realize that the
highest risk patients in that group
deserve a chance at intervention that
could improve their otherwise very poor
prospects for five-year survival
and so there's a level 2b recommendation
in the published nccm guidelines
that tells clinicians to look for the
high risk patients among stage 1
and earmark them for chemotherapy
now how in the absence of any novel
technology for differentiating uh stages
within the
clinical pathologic tnm system
how did the nccn
recommend to clinicians that they go
ahead and identify these high-risk
patients well they say first look in
stage 1b because by definition stage 1b
is higher risk than stage 1a and then
among those high-risk patients use
available anatomic and histologic
criteria to guess essentially which of
those patients are going to be at
highest risk
now those criteria you know are again
derived from past literature
and
so it's quite reasonable in the absence
of any better data for those to be used
to help guide
important clinical uh strategic
therapeutic decisions
but there's never been any large-scale
validation
certainly that those criteria identify
patients who benefit from chemotherapy
and to be honest there really isn't
great validation out there that those
criteria do the best job at identifying
stage even stage 1b patients at the
highest risk
still we have this nccn recommendation
on the books
and
it has to be taken in context that the
default level of evidence for nccn
guidelines for this disease is
level 2a so we don't have level 1
perspective randomized evidence
for a large number of the
recommendations and decisions that are
made in managing these patients
but we're recognizing that we need to
move forward with our patients making
important potentially life and death
decisions with these patients using the
best available information and
synthesizing that information into the
most logical most appropriate approach
for each individual patient
so as we've sort of been building the
case uh in the past 10 to 15 minutes if
we had even more accurate prognostic
information we could even better
identify patients even in stage 1 and
certainly in stage 2 who are very likely
to harbor undetected metastatic disease
after surgery who could potentially
derive a life-saving benefit from
adjuvant intervention
all right if there is a need for better
prognostic information and the world of
breast cancer has already taught us that
molecular prognostics could be a very
reliable means to get at that
information beyond t m staging
how has the lung cancer research
community responded to this challenge
well our group was certainly not the
first uh certainly not the only group to
recognize the need for this better
prognostic information
in the management of early-stage lung
cancer there have been at least 15 if
not more very well-run scientific
studies all
aimed at the development of a system for
better molecular based prognosis
all of the studies though that have been
published prior to our most recent work
worked with frozen tissue that was
dropped in liquid nitrogen in the
operating room
to best preserve the messenger rna and
therefore get the best possible
signal about gene expression patterns in
that tissue into the researchers hands
but we all know that that's not a very
practical approach
toward the community management of our
patients with non-small cell lung cancer
it's really limiting the research to a
very pristine level of information
and tissue that's not going to translate
into widespread clinical application
furthermore many of these studies
because they had such high quality rna
relied on a microarray approach to
analyzing gene expression patterns
that's also very difficult to
turn into a very reliable reproducible
regimen
in clinton in the application in the
real clinical world
and limits the potential applicability
of that research as you move to a wide
wide scale basis
the end result has been that although
we've had small to medium scale studies
from a large number of groups certainly
proving the principle that molecular
prognosis is achievable in non-small
cell lung cancer
none of those small to medium scale
studies have achieved a truly blinded
large scale validation
and the one study that did attempt a
blinded validation really failed to
yield a very convincing validation
particularly among stage one patients
who are such an important target
and so experts in the field
have sort of extracted from this body of
data that we really need a
practical and reproducible assay with
large scale independent validation
and that was a challenge that we
undertook at ucsf
in
pursuing this type of program
so
we realized that we needed to start with
a very large
cohort of patients to train our assay to
develop our assay and we decided that we
would start with rna derived only from
tariffs and tissues for this project
because we know that it's only rna from
paraffin tissues that's going to be
widely available in the community in the
foreseeable future
now
based on research that we also had
undertaken in fresh frozen tissue that
gave us a clue boiling down from
hundreds of candidate genes a set of
about a dozen genes that were likely to
tell an important story about non-small
cell lung cancer we developed a
quantitative pcr approach
for again about a dozen active cancer
genes and
several what we call housekeeping or
control genes so that we could very
reliably using a very
standard state-of-the-art pcr technology
measure gene expression
from patients tumors from pathology labs
around the country and literally around
the world
we used um
various means of
trying to
really boil down our
molecular prognostic
formula
so that it would not reflect
idiosyncrasies
of our training or teaching cohort but
that it was more likely to reflect the
fundamental molecular biology of this
disease
and then we realized that the proof of
the pudding was definitely going to be
in the eating in terms of getting
clinicians to be able to rely on these
data to make clinical judgments about
their individual patients and so we
realized the most important part of our
program was the truly independent
and blinded clinical validation that
needed to be undertaken once we had our
best possible assay with an algorithm
that had gone through very tight
statistical lingers
and so we turned to
colleagues in the clinical research
world who could help us not only here in
the san francisco bay area where we were
able to engage the help of the kaiser
northern california research institute
and cull uh through them patients from
all over northern california community
hospitals managed in their system
but we also
looked
to the west to the far east if you will
where
we had been working with colleagues
leading clinical
experts in leading centers in mainland
china with whom we've been able to build
a brand new clinical research
organization called the china clinical
trials consortium
that involved the collaboration between
established western leaders in clinical
cancer research
and leaders in the delivery of
outstanding state-of-the-art clinical
care in leading centers in china and
build uh more of a workhorse that could
get large-scale clinical validation and
other clinical trials done in a much
shorter period of time than could be
achieved under standard conditions here
in the west
now just to quickly run through uh the
technology that's reflected
in the process of this molecular assay
we start with
absolutely normal formula and fixed
paraffin embedded samples
we extract
rna
from this paraffin recognizing that the
rna
is highly fragmented
suffering from
heat and uh rna's degradation
but the rna fragments are
of a high enough quality and this has
been proven now
again over the past decade or so
that this low quality rna is still good
enough for us to derive very reliable uh
gene expression information if we have a
quantitative rt pcr system that is
designed specifically for these types of
fragmented rna samples and is very
rigorously tested
once we measure uh gene expression
patterns we then developed an algorithm
again using very stringent statistical
criteria so that we get a risk score in
the end that can differentiate between
patients that are low risk
high risk and we have an intermediate
group of patients in this assay uh that
are sitting in between the highest and
lowest risk patients well as i mentioned
we decided uh to undertake two parallel
uh validation studies uh that included
roughly 450 patients from northern
california and roughly a thousand
patients from the china clinical trials
consortium when those two independent
studies were done uh the editors at the
lancet uh
asked us to present uh the results of
those landmark studies in a single
publication uh that appeared in press in
march of 2012
and there was really a very large cadre
of international uh cancer research
leaders that participated in that effort
and it really uh has yielded one of the
largest um
clinical validations of a molecular
prognostic for a cancer of any sort
and
just to give you a little bit more of a
background about whom
we're dealing with and and whose data uh
you're reading about when you hear about
the china clinical trials consortium
the core group uh were leaders from the
major metropolitan centers beijing
shanghai and guangzhou on the eastern
seaboard of china
since the early founding of the
organization we've been able to bring in
leaders from other major metropolitan
centers from around china
and
more recently we've begun to branch out
into other
cancer types as well
and you can see there are now vast
resources available to augment the
clinical research uh that the same
western leaders who are involved in the
clinical trials consortium in china are
able to achieve uh in western patient
populations
so what what are the actual validation
data well
when we got the independent analyses
back from these two studies uh
we were impressed by
the similarity between the separation of
patient outcome data
between high intermediate and low risk
patients that we achieved in these
vastly different
patient populations again northern
california
and uh the china clinical trials
consortium
i might point out at this point that the
china consortium recruited patients from
stages 1 through 3a in other words all
comers
for early stage
non-small cell lung cancer resection
and you can see the separation that's
achieved
among
the entire population on the left side
of the screen there
in the china consortium the kaiser study
really focused on stage one patients uh
here in the united states for whom we
have a particular conundrum because we
know a lot of those patients are
destined to die from their lung cancer
and yet
for the majority of those patients
we don't offer any intervention
after surgery alone and you can see
again a very clear separation
of high intermediate and low risk
patients and i might point out that you
can see from this graph that the high
risk patients even in stage one alone in
the kaiser cohort
have a five-year survival of only
approximately 50 percent
now
one of the caveats that leaders in this
field established as an absolute
requirement for any reliable molecular
prognostic system is that it truly be
independent of stage and i might point
out here that it's only gene expression
data uh culled from the analysis of 14
genes which are 11
active cancer genes and three
housekeeping genes it's only the data
about gene expression
that drives the
derivation of the risk score that
separates patients into high
intermediate and low risk for five-year
survival
there are no clinical uh covariates
involved in the derivation of that risk
score
and when you look at
risk score within individual stages of
disease you see the same type of
separation of high intermediate and low
risk patients based on actual outcome
and so you can see here in the china
cohort stage 1 stage 2 patients are
clearly separated
individually based on a molecular risk
score alone
now
it's important to look at
multivariate univariate analysis to
understand how this risk score compares
to other predictors of outcome
and uh
suffice it to say
that
both univariate and importantly
multivariate analysis really confirmed
that compared to any of the available
clinical pathologic criteria
a high risk designation by molecular
prognostic analysis which was a much
more meaningful
and a much more telling indicator of
five year survival
than any of the other uh clinical
pathologic covariates either alone or
when adjusted in a multivariate approach
and i might point out that the one
factor that clinicians have tended to
rely on the most uh in terms of deciding
whether or not a stage one or a stage
one be patient is going to be a
candidate for early
systemic adjuvant intervention
is that size of the tumor so even among
stage 1b patients because of a little
bit of data that we have available from
the cal gb 9633 study in which a post
hoc retrospective analysis
of those data allowed identification of
a four centimeter cut off that did
identify patients in that study
who did see a benefit from a systemic
adjuvant chemotherapeutic intervention
when you compare
the true prognostic uh reliability of
tumor size greater than four centimeters
with high risk designation based on the
molecular prognostic
you can see that there's really no
comparison in terms of the value of the
prognostic information
uh with the high risk of molecular
categorization being a much more uh
telling a
hazard ratio of
2.04 compared to
the much smaller hazard ratio associated
with tumor size
now
we did of course a similar uh
uh
cox
proportional hazards modeling with our
china cohort
and we see a very similar story
that
both univariate and multivariate
analysis confirm that a high risk
designation uh by this molecular assay
is truly indicative
of
a uh poor prognosis even in the presence
and even after adjusting for other
clinical covariates what's interesting
about the china cohort is that we now
have the ability uh now have the ability
to adjust for tnm stage itself and of
course tnm stage should be must be an
accurate predictor of outcome otherwise
there's something very wrong in the
state of denmark
and you can see that even when adjusting
for stage itself
there's still a 2.4
hazard ratio associated with a high risk
designation that is
extremely clinically significant so that
we truly are going above and beyond uh
clinical pathologic tnm staging and
identifying patients in all stages after
resection who are at the highest risk of
death within five years of surgery
at this point i want to just bring the
discussion back very briefly to a point
i made earlier
even though the tnm staging system that
was introduced in 2009
benefited from a very large cohort of
patients both in terms of derivation
of criteria for t m categorization as
well as validation of the new system
only about two thousand patients in
stage one
actually uh were available for
validation of
the new tnm system
well we have looked at nearly a thousand
stage one patients
in our combined uh kaiser and china
clinical trials consortium independent
validation studies so we're really uh
i should say a thousand patients just in
stage one alone so we're really talking
about a scale of validation of this
molecular molecular prognostic that is
quite similar to the scalar validation
for the tnm system that's used to guide
just about every management decision
in early stage lung cancer
let me take a brief step back and just
re-emphasize that that this assay
is targeted just for patients with a
non-squamous histology
and
let me explain that uh
the reason behind that is that
we're we really decided to let the
biology of the tumors uh as reflected by
their molecular
gene expression profiling
tell us what were the most important
factors in determining uh outcome
and the biology of squamous cell
carcinoma really is a very different
beast from the biology of non-squamous
disease
and if we tried to lump these very
different biological entities together
we knew we would be introducing a lot
more noise into the system and that the
likelihood of being able to reflect that
system back out into the wide community
of international patients would be much
less likely to succeed
and this was based uh not only on work
with these paraffin samples but again on
preliminary studies that we had done
with many hundreds of fresh frozen
samples that really confirmed what the
literature had already established which
is that there's a fundamental difference
in the biology of squamous cell
carcinoma and the
various non-squamous varieties that we
see
in
in lung cancer
and so this assay is really
derived
and applicable just to non-squamous
histologies
now uh
this is a molecular prognostic test it's
not a diagnostic test and so uh
there are
measurements of statistical accuracy
such as uh
specificity
um
and um
positive predictive value that are
relevant
when evaluating a diagnostic test that
is a very definitive type of test that
gives you a clear diagnosis
those
statistical tools are simply not
available when you're dealing with a
probabilistic test like this one that
gives you a prognosis in terms of risk
but not a diagnosis in terms of a
definitive
categorization of a patient
so there will be high-risk patients who
certainly will survive five years and
low-risk patients who will succumb to
their disease
what we're talking about is better
identifying the degree of risk so that a
better clinical decision can be made for
each individual patient
so when you compare different tools
for probabilistic or what are also known
as stochastic tests instead of looking
at sensitivity and specificity we have
to use other means to gauge a
probabilistic assignment of patients to
risk groups the auroch or area under the
receiving operator curve is a tool that
has been very well established
in the evaluation of probabilistic or
risk
assessment tests certainly in other
areas such as the realm of
cardiovascular disease where risk
assessment has been an important part of
patient management for many many years
and when we used an auroch approach to
compare this molecular assay
to for example the nccn criteria for
identifying high-risk patients in stage
one
who should be uh earmarked and
recommended and designated for early
chemotherapeutic intervention
uh trust me in in
interpreting these curves for you that
there is a dramatic improvement in the
accuracy of the information when we
considered the molecular prognosis
and didn't rely solely on the nccn
criteria to identify high-risk patients
what does that mean in simple terms it
means that if nccn is recommending that
we identify high-risk stage 1 patients
because those patients are very likely
to harbor undetected metastatic disease
and therefore are likely based on
existing literature to derive benefit
from systemic intervention that could
address that systemic disease
this molecular test is now very clearly
documented to be a better means of
identifying those high-risk patients in
stage one
now when you think about um the future
and the immediate future hopefully will
involve a greater degree of screening
for early stage lung cancer and
therefore identifying earlier and
earlier stage patients for management
and for intervention
we realized that there may be a lot of
very small tumors coming down the pike
in lung cancer and recently there's
actually been some very interesting
science and uh notice of that science in
the late press
that we may need to rethink our approach
to the earliest stage of patients with a
variety of cancers who are identified
through aggressive screening programs
because the outcomes for those patients
may not be the same as the outcomes for
all comers
who were identified in the days before
aggressive screening
well one thing that we know is that
screening for lung cancer particularly
with a
a
low-dose high-resolution ct scanning
approach is very likely to identify a
lot more patients with very small tumors
nodules that are eventually proven to be
a non-small cell lung cancer
and so when we think not only of stage
one not only of stage 1a but actually
t1a tumors in other words tumors that
are not only early stage but actually
less than two centimeters in maximum
diameter
we may
want to know
how many of those patients are likely to
harbor metastatic disease
because
traditional data have told us that even
those patients with the smallest tumors
iet1a patients still are at very high
risk with non-small cell lung cancer to
harbor undetected metastatic disease
and see so we undertook a separate
analysis
that was published uh last fall in jama
just about one year ago
in which we looked specifically only at
uh t1a tumors uh with n zero uh
designation so these are the earliest
possible uh stage of patients that that
undergo surgery and come back to the
surgeon's office uh for
an assessment uh at that early post-op
visit
so these earliest stage patients where
where we normally reassure have the best
possible prognosis
but by running this molecular assay we
were able to identify a third of
patients so out of about 270 patients
about 90 of those patients were
designated as high risk by the molecular
assay and those patients had a 50
mortality when we looked at their
outcomes so even among the lowest risk
patients who by almost any conventional
standard would be sent off and offered
no possible intervention to lower uh
their chances of succumbing to lung
cancer within five years
we are now able to identify a very
important very large
patient subpopulation
who are at very high risk for mortality
and since they're succumbing in general
to um
distant metastatic disease these are
patients who are leaving our offices
with undetected metastasis who are very
likely to be the ones to derive the most
benefit from systemic intervention and
now we have a means available
to offer them uh something different
other than just uh observation and a
wish for the best of luck
so to summarize uh the information and
uh
some of the conclusions i've attempted
to put in front of you today i think
it's clear that the thirty to sixty
percent mortality uh for early stage
lung cancer even after attempts at
curative resection is really not
acceptable particularly in the face of
of improvements that we've achieved in
survival for other solid cancers
i hope i've convinced you that we now
have a very robust and very practical
assay available
again it's known as provenial lung rs
and
anyone can go to the web and get more
information about ordering this test for
their early stage patients
but importantly this test has undergone
a very rigorous blinded independent
validation program that
means that the data are reliable
and can be used to help guide clinical
decision making
in the here and now
again
this new prognostic system is
independent of a conventional tnm
criteria and other clinical pathologic
criteria
and it's actually been documented uh to
do a more reliable job of identifying
patients in stage one who are very high
risk of disease
so
if conventional staging
doesn't get us to where we want to be
right now
and as a result many of our early stage
lung cancer patients are succumbing to
distant metastasis
perhaps
it's time to look for a way to access
better
informed decisions and therefore
a better uh management decisions for
patients who may very well stand to
derive a great deal of intervention a
great deal of benefit from early
intervention for their early metastatic
disease and let me remind you again
that the data that are available from
prospective randomized studies suggests
that we're not only able to slightly
prolong survival as we are in late stage
lung cancer but we may actually be able
to cure some patients with early
metastatic disease if we intervene early
and certainly achieve more than just a
few months
of added survival to their lives
and we've tended to see the greatest
benefit among patients who are at the
greatest risk which means that those
patients deserve to be identified and as
and deserve to be offered a greater
array of therapeutic options
again there are standing recommendations
out there to use the best possible
prognostic information to make better
decisions even for stage one patients
for whom we don't yet have prospective
randomized data on improving uh their
outlook for survival
but
we facing these difficult decisions
right now and it's rarely been the case
in clinical medicine that better
information has not led uh to better
decision making and ultimately better
outcomes for our patients
so
right now we're left with a perception
of risk among early stage lung cancer
patients
but
it's it's truly a perception based on a
system that doesn't really distinguish
very very well between patients who've
been cured by surgery and those who
harbor very significant whether it's
thirty percent or sixty to seventy
percent risk
of uh harboring undetected metastatic
disease
we can now take that perception of low
risk and use a molecular prognostic tool
to really tell us who's at low risk who
really uh should be managed simply with
monitoring uh and watchful waiting
and who are truly at high risk despite
uh
pathologic criteria
patients who not only
deserve closer monitoring perhaps but
actually early intervention that may
modify their risk and really reduce
their risk of late stage a recurrence
down the road
now it would be remiss for me not to
mention
uh the
plethora of really talented uh
uh and dedicated individuals who
contributed to the research that i
presented to you today
my close friend and colleague dave
jablons
who
worked with me together in managing
this
research program from its beginnings
really all the way through
these more recent large-scale
validations i'd also like to mention
johannes kratz a very brilliant young
thoracic surgeon coming out of the mass
general system who will be joining our
faculty
at the ucsf uh in the summer
as well as again a cadre of other folks
both here in the united states in
california and across the ocean in the
china clinical trials consortium
now i've been asked uh to remind folks
that uh you can sign up for uh
cme and ce credit uh by accessing the
website that's uh on the screen right
now at
bioconferencelive.com
and i believe a number of questions uh
have been uh typed in during the course
of the lecture
and uh i can uh try to run through some
of those questions for you now and uh
give you a little bit more detailed
information
so again i'll read some of these
questions for you
uh and uh and answer them as best i can
in the next 10 minutes or so
first question was rna from the ffp
samples extracted using the same
sample prep protocol
and i assume uh that the question is
referring to
both the research that we did in
developing the assay
as well as the assay as it's run now in
the clia certified laboratory uh that's
run by life technologies uh out here in
california
and by uh any and all laboratories that
may have been involved in the validation
studies
well first of all let me reassure you
that uh all of the data that went into
uh the validation studies that were
published in the lancet
and later in jama
were run under
uh clia conditions uh and were uh clio
clear valid assays uh if they were run
on patients in the united states
and that uh a essentially clear
equivalent laboratory was actually
established in china
in one centralized location
to run uh the specimens on the patients
there so it was absolutely the identical
assay
that was run in the validation studies
that can be accessed by patients and
clinicians now
uh through
a a very rigorously certified uh clear
program and clear laboratory
run by life technologies
and to specifically answer this question
absolutely uh we have uh ever since
establishing the assay used uh one
standard uh very rigorous rna extraction
protocol
that really takes into consideration
some of the unique properties of this
lung cancer tissue
and the type of rna that we can derive
from formula fixed paraffin embedded
specimens
uh the next question
uh on the list is how did the ffpe and
fresh frozen samples correlate
very good question
uh because the earliest data in our
program was derived from a fresh frozen
tissue in which we boil down
hundreds of candidate genes to a cadre
first of about 200 genes that we studied
very intensely
that was boiled down to about 60 genes
that told a story about early stage lung
cancer
and finally the dozen or so genes that
have been incorporated into the actual
assay
so it is relevant and it is important
to understand um how the data from ffp
samples to correlate back to fresh
frozen samples in which the rna is quite
frankly of a higher quality
and as is reported uh
in our publication material i believe if
you go
to the supplement for the lancet you'll
see
some data regarding this question there
was
very very close correlation
not only in terms of the individual
degree of gene expression that we were
able to achieve through our very
rigorously developed ffpe
uh rna extraction uh and quantitative
pcr system because those two really go
together closely hand in hand
we developed an rq-pcr system that was
customized to perform
with
rna that's extracted from ffp samples
specifically from lung cancer tumor
tissue
so there was not only a high degree of
correlation in gene expression data but
certainly with the risk scores and the
risk categorization that's achieved
there was very tight correlation between
what what we were able to see when we
had fresh frozen samples available in
those samples in which uh we also worked
with uh for formalin fix to paraffin
embedded tissue
the next question uh asks about the um
uh
area under the receiver operating curve
analysis i i believe and and the
question is uh
how high a number and it's actually a c
statistic uh that is the actual a
statistical entity that one can derive
from an uh
an area under the receiver operating
curve uh analysis
um and that c statistic
for those who are not so familiar with
this area of statistical analysis and
research
is really telling you what is the
fidelity
if you compare two different uh in this
case prognostic systems or probabilistic
systems
what is the fidelity if you compare on
an individual patient an individual
basis in this case patient per patient
or sample for sample
what is the fidelity if you compare a
risk categorization
or any categorization for that matter uh
between two samples is a higher risk
category likely to give you
a a
worse outcome
uh when you compare two systems
again on an individual basis side by
side
and unfortunately when we looked at the
auroch analysis
for
the nccn criteria which is all we have
now for identifying high-risk stage 1
patients who deserve a better shot at
survival
the
the c-statistic uh using tnm plus
clinical pathologic criteria wasn't much
better than 0.5 uh which suggests that
you're dealing with uh something close
to the toss of a coin in terms of
relying on those criteria to decide
whether a patient is truly high risk or
not
and uh the prognostic system uh that i
should say the prognostic information
available from the molecular uh test
was uh i believe closer to uh 0.6
uh which tells you that at least you're
moving away
from the toss of a coin
and you're really getting a uh
an answer that's much more
meaningful
to the clinician in terms of guiding a
treatment decision
uh and the p value associated with the
comparison of those c statistics was
extremely small
uh
less than .001
i might also point out again for those
who are familiar
or i should say unfamiliar with this
system that the um c statistic itself
uh
doesn't uh give you any kind of
quantitative assessment
for uh the
the improvement of uh one system uh over
another and a a classic example is that
uh an improved uh an increase in c
statistic uh on the order of 0.01 or
0.02
is all that we've seen by incorporating
very meaningful prognostic elements into
analyses
in cardiovascular disease such as
hdl and ldl cholesterol levels
and i think a related question
again and again i i thank the audience
for these questions because it does help
me once again to address this important
issue
um this question asks um
what was the positive predictive and
negative predictive value so again
uh
let me
emphasize that when you're dealing with
a probabilistic
test of any sort
it's impossible to derive
a positive and negative predictive value
because it's not a deterministic test
so there is no way uh to derive a
specificity
or a
sensitivity because you're not giving a
definitive a diagnosis or definitive
designation to the patient you're
assigning them to risk category and
you're letting the patient know that
you're at a relatively high or
relatively low risk of a particular
outcome so it's virtually impossible
to derive and and therefore impossible
to think about
positive predictive values or negative
predictive values or sensitivities or
specificities when you're dealing with a
probabilistic system but that is all we
could possibly do and that's what the
tnm
approach itself is it's nothing more
than a probabilistic system
it's a
prognostic approach based on
retrospective analysis of patient
outcomes that is t m staging and
unfortunately the probabilistic
information that we get from tm staging
in early stage lung cancer just isn't
crisp and um
discriminatory enough for us to really
know which of those patients are truly
high or low risk for harboring
metastatic disease and so what we know
from the auroch analysis
is that since you do need to rely on
some type of probabilistic assessment
for patient risk in order to decide
whether or not
the individual patient is a good
candidate for chemotherapy or not you
want to have the best possible most
reliable possible information regarding
risk level and
potential outcome and that's where this
assay outshines uh the traditional tnm
approach alone even combined with other
clinical pathologic criteria
and that's where the auric analysis is
really very meaningful and very helpful
because it tells you very definitively
that if you rely on the molecular
prognostic rather than just clinical
pathologic criteria alone you're going
to get a much more accurate designation
of each patient in terms of high or low
risk for recurrence
so there's no way to think about
positive or negative predictive values
because there's no way to diagnose these
patients with undetectable metastasis or
not
but we're dealing with a different set
of tools ones that guide us toward the
best possible uh clinical decision given
that the information and the tools we
have available
so i hope all of that information has
been helpful
again i'll
refer you back to the website
that um uh
you can use to uh sign up for uh ce and
cm credit
and i thank you very much uh for your
participation in this seminar and uh i
look forward to addressing uh other
questions that folks might have
uh through uh email and other means that
we have possible
again thank you very very much